all I'm saying is if there was one
actually aesthetic thing that I could my
body if I had a nice I'll be hyp let's
see what you're working with now let's
see guys you guys are going to shame me
let's see where you're at do it and no
arching Nach na oh you got a good butt
dude you got some c a good butt you just
brought that up cuz you want to show it
yeah humo brag in in 10 years not very
[Laughter]
[Music]
popular welcome back to careful boys we
are very careful boys and today we're
talking about what do you think
is popular right
now like what it
mean I was going to say i' like to
answer that I was going to say [__]
being a [__] as popular right now it be
it'd be funny just to like rattle off a
couple
things I might like by the way I might
like that mistake prompt better than the
prompt we'll see let's just let's just
leave it let's just leave it you want to
leave it really well cuz the other one
okay okay let's do pitch pitch room real
quick pitch what do you think will be
ridiculous in 10 years that is currently
super popular oh I like I like all of it
they're both good that that'll be at the
the 12 minute Mark let's ask these guys
what's popular right now we're all
[__] out of touch and [__] Tik Tok
popular oh you know what's popular right
now uh [__] Timothy shamay and uh
Kylie Jenner or whatever the [__] her
name oh yeah they're dating right Golden
Globes right they're all like looking
into each other's eyes
you think that stuff that happens is
like a plant yeah could be like PR stuff
yeah so premeditated they're playing a
different game and [__] you know there's
an actual I think there's like a roster
that they all like do like trading cards
and they're like oh they're single I
think their career would be great if
they match up we have some homies we
have some homies that work in the The
Biz and they constantly talk about how
like they think Michael B Jordan and
Lori Harvey weren't even really dating
no it's just it's just a plant one of
them one of theom works for Lori Harvey
or something they were like they would
never even they would link up Pap razu
would come by but then they would never
like yeah hang out I mean that makes
sense they got the news story and it's
like if it's beneficial mutually and
you're not in a space where you even are
trying to like date or anything like
that like who the [__] cares so who are
we going to set Anthony up with so we
get popularity my wife yeah okay all
right I was talking I was talking to
someone who me and Nick me and Nick I
was talking to somebody who's like oh
like I've been dating Michael B Jordan
and I was like I think you're just
blowing
him yeah that's a different scenario or
like do you think like Nick Kon after
kid like 14 is like I might as well go
for the record you know what I'm saying
like if I'm already notorious for it
like what's another like four or five
children or something like that so that
I can guarantee like in the legendary
history books I had like 19 bastard
children or some [__] you know what I
mean damn I guess I don't know I don't
know what we mean no oh that's not
popular enough then yeah not popular so
Nick K is not popular he's not popular
right now he could be popular oh he's
popular for sure yeah you know what I'm
worried about you know how a lot of
people they'll get like a tattoo right
when they're dumb and then like 10 years
later they regret it and they're like
[__] what about all the people that been
chopping their dicks off or like cutting
other [__] off and doing it back on 10
years later how do we know what about
the people chopping their dick I hope
nobody regrets that I know it's pretty
popular though that's a thing is it's
really popular it's the most popular
it's ever been do you think
circumcisions are ever going to go out
oh that's a good question I wanted to
get circumcised but now I don't anymore
me too come on do it no no way dude when
did you want to get circumcised last
year no when I was a kid and all the
homies were circumcised you felt left
out I was like oh man I'm a freak that's
Apparently one of the leading reasons
why parents still do it yeah cuz they
don't want social shame yeah they don't
want their kid to be like in the locker
room or some [__] and like yeah well
they know my pain I saw everyone else's
and I was like man why is mine got like
a weird ant
look I mean cuz when you're a kid
everyone goes peed together right it's
fun I don't really do that that much I
think dude you didn't do that
kindergarten or like first grade like
six kids peeing in the toilet bowl we
had like six kids just peeing in the
toilet bowl all right stop yelling at me
about it I remember when it was like
when one kid was like I got to go
bathroom I was like I do too and then
there'll be like four other boys we got
to go to the bathroom and then we all
went in to the same
stall dude you guys can't aim back then
you're hitting each other Friendly Fire
everywhere oh you know what's probably
not popular that's probably not popular
now pee together yeah you you don't
think kids are pee together like think
about how shy kids are now together yeah
I think people aren't as like tight
anymore you know you know it's a weird
this is like kind of a hot take but like
I've been just seeing a lot of material
about this and I don't feel this way
because I love these dudes but there's a
lot of talk about how when Joe Rogan
blew up he made a lot of not that great
comedians Super Famous and there's a lot
banking on that they won't be popular in
10 years oh interesting like the
comedians that he that he that he put on
are you just talking about Brendan shop
well that's one of them but like there's
a whole slew of like you know all of his
homies that like basically like got put
on are the main dudes right now like
that yeah but but then now they're
starting to like not fall off but like I
think there's a lot of material that's
like counterculture again countering
yeah which I think is a natural thing
that happens anyways yeah it always
happens but I think that's a pretty
interesting take you know something
that's less interesting sure check this
out um love to hear so confirm this for
me but I've seen a bunch of random like
Fitness memes and trends that are
talking about how in 2024 the new trend
for men is a nice butt a big butt oh
yeah bro dudes are going to get some
crazy cakes have you seen bar BR that's
what I'm saying though he's like always
leading the game yeah but is that a gay
Trend I mean like in the gay community
gay is trending well gay is trending
like butts though yeah they always like
buts he's right remember like those
those '90s and ' 80s like dudes with the
high pants and girls are always like
what stopping men from dressing like
this today all I'm saying is if there
was one actually aesthetic thing that I
could my body if I had a nice ass I'll
be hyp let's see what you're working
with now let's see you don't have a nice
ass let's see where you're at see what
kind of you don't have a good ass guys
you guys are going to shame me let's see
where you're at do it and no arching no
arching Nach na oh you got a good butt
dude you got some cake butt you got a
high and TI that's a good butt you just
brought that up cuz you want to show
your ass yeah humo brag in 10 years not
very
popular that's H funny Steve can we see
your
butt get in there dude we're in this bro
Steve's got a build bro you want you
want to see something less
interesting dicks only yeah you just
wanted to show your dick I'd rather have
a big dick than a big
ass yeah do you know what I I think is
going to be less popular in 10 years is
uh oh God this is going to suck
championing overweight Beauty yeah cuz
they all going to die dude I think
that's already happening right now I
think in 10 years that's I think we're
like kind of in the thick of it and then
after some time it's going to be like o
we shouldn't have done that you see that
one viral girl's Tik Tok 11 that one
viral girl who's like she basically took
all these clips of like people that are
like you know oh that's Blair white dude
she's that's a
transgender uh uh
uh yeah that's her she she did the whole
clips of she goes she's dead she's dead
yeah yeah she's transgender yeah she's
hot what did she said yeah
what [__] JK no where did she live where
so she shows clips of different like uh
people who are like oh I don't like they
have a fat lifestyle and they love it
and they're like all about eating and
getting bigger and then she's like then
the screen goes gray and she goes she
died it's like all she basically goes
okay she's a she's a radio host and then
and then and and then like 3 seconds
later she's dead goes this one's a fat
positive this and that model she's dead
got it yeah damn it's like six or seven
like giant people and she just
influencers he died too that's a good I
think that's good because like what Ryan
was saying we've been stretching the
mozzarella like like we you go to a
doctor's office right since we were a
kid in elementary school you get your
[__] BMI whatever there's like like
very objective metrics of body fat
percentage cholesterol that stuff of
like what healthy is or even the healthy
average range is cuz healthy there is a
range right and clearly there's uh
physiques and metrics outside of this
range and then we're so focused on
acceptance rather than changing Behavior
to get back in range yeah and it's like
man of course people are going to die
yeah that's why I think we're going to
find the point where it's like don't
make fat people hate themselves but
don't make them love themselves too much
yeah yeah cuz that's not healthy either
yeah it's like it's that middle it's
that middle thing it's like it is crazy
though because even in the comments of
like that video it the the comments are
so polarized right like it's there's no
in between right there's no middle
ground yeah people are either extreme
like yeah they deserve to die or some
[__] or other people are like this is
[__] up because you should accept blah
blah and it's like there's nothing in
between there's not like one guy who
goes in there it's like guys you know
there's a certain range that is actually
healthy so you know maybe we shouldn't
like tell people that they should hate
themselves you know what I mean like
nobody's being practical even a really
good-looking guy shouldn't love himself
too much it's like either way it's like
don't don't stretch the
mo don't the keep the M you know yeah
cuz even like you know the bodybuilders
are competing at that moment they're
like the most ripped dude in the in the
universe but they even know that's not
healthy either yeah they're like it's
not even healthy to be that low body
percentage it's not sustainable so it's
like if we know that's the case on this
end what about on this end I just don't
understand people that are like I'm
perfectly healthy and a month later they
die from [__] heart attack and [__]
it's like you're not that healthy yeah
and it's fine if like that's your choice
and you just want to like get as big as
you can and die that's cool but don't
call yourself healthy but don't preach
it to other people like oh don't even
bother like working out just be bigger
like that's crazy to say some people are
like doctors and they're like they're
they're like the overweight doctor or
something like that or beast doctor and
they talk about how like it's okay to be
obese for an extended period of time and
it's
like you know what's crazy this wouldn't
even fly out a vet you know that the
what it won't even fly out of vet like
if you bring a dog that's supposed to be
60 lb and if the dog is like 70 or 80 lb
you bring them the vet will be like oh
you need to stop feeding them as much
they're like what the [__] you doing to
your dog yeah like even this would even
fly out a vet come down on you like if
you had like a buff pit bull and you
couldn't see like the pit bull's like
buff shoulders anymore the the vet would
be like hey we need to like curb some
some of this food so I'm like if we
already if we're objective with animals
how come we're not even objective with
because it's a fat phobic doctor I saw I
saw a vet on Tik Tok who's like some
dogs are just big it's totally fine it's
completely healthy that's I saw that
really sounds like Tik Tok is I'm
surprised you watched Tik Tok no I
didn't watch that [__] what are you
talking about that's what I would expect
to see from from this current where
where do you think uh veganism is going
to be in 10 years in the trash they're
all going to be dead too yeah yeah yeah
[__] vitamin B deficiency is where
they're going to be the seed oils uh
stuff is coming back now like all the
talk about seed oil stuff it's like it's
like being rained in a little bit that's
actually good though because that [__]
[__] a lot of people up the thing
about the seed o I think they were
saying that like it's really bad for you
if it's like heated a bunch over and
over and over again canola oil yeah as
long as it's not like um been overused
like in frying oils then you should be
kind of good but that's who knows who
knows that's going to probably change a
dude that's like red wine it's like red
Wine's really bad for you red Wine's
great for you have a glass a day what
the [__] it all goes back and forth like
red meat cholesterol and then they go
wait cholesterol is actually really good
for testosterone and all this stuff and
they go saturated fats is awful for you
for like 20 years and they're like ah
it's actually fine you know what cuz
it's like two guys writing articles
that's why [__] there one guy writing
an article and then you know gets a
bunch of AD play on it those Stanley
Cups are going to be out in a year
probably I got I got one at the house
right you got the peak one
you got the pink one I got the 64 but it
don't matter they got 10 years of
Revenue in [__] one year I do wish
they were a little bit bigger bigger cuz
I'll drink it how many you got oh I
don't know but I'll drink it throughout
the day and I'm like [__] I got to
refill again that's why you get the 64 o
I think I have a biggest n dude you
don't got I think that pronoun stuff
will probably be out of here you think
so out of here it's so confusing so
[__] whack and gay it's hard to keep
up with well it's just hard to it's hard
to like actually talk to anybody like if
they're in the if they're in that zone
it's hard to actually have a
conversation I just think they'll grow
out of it yeah that's true huh you
probably will grow out of it cuz like I
I can't imagine like trying to it's like
trying to keep up a conversation It's
like got to remember you going to do
this when you're 45 yeah you know what I
mean you want to be you know yeah that's
true you're going to be they theming it
at at
50 when you're introducing yourself or
like you have a [__] medical
emergency and someone gets rolled in on
a stretch or the unconscious I don't
know the if they a penis but is a she
they wh I don't know don't invalidate
their feelings right yeah it's like and
I feel like people have been living with
all this stuff in the culture for long
enough to the point where they're like
we can we could do without it probably
you know let's let's make it simpler
just like a like overall the normal I
think the extreme I think the extreme
side's going to calm down yeah cuz the
normal normal folks are just like I
don't really know about all this I think
we should draw the line at left-handed
right-handed yeah that's it that's it
yeah don't give left-handed any
rights and by the way I have a family
member who's who's trans and like I
call I say the right one every day see
see how hard it is it's just [__]
hard but the best thing about it is that
they don't freak the [__] out on you if
you do [__] up right it's like a really
reasonable thing it's not like how the
internet does it where you're like you
just dead named them and you piece of
[__] you're making them want to kill
themselves and [__] it's like what are
you that's the part that I think is
really misleading is that like most
people's day-to-day interactions don't
end that way but online it looks like
everyone reacts like that but it's not
true yeah cuz it's like 10 crazy
[__] yeah and you see the you
see actual like transgender people that
are like you're [__] crazy stop
you're making it worse for us in real
life when you actually hang out with
people you can't be like that or nobody
wants to hang out with you so you well
they probably have no friends that's why
they're online commenting all day
exactly yeah do you think that level of
commenting is going to be popular in 10
years I think it'll always be yeah I
think anonymity is is a thing that has
to go before that changes I think
that'll be completely wiped out if
everybody's [__] real name in face
was that you put your ID on cuz it's
exactly the same thing where in person
nobody talks to each other like that
yeah most of those [__] got like an
Anime Avatar or something and they it's
not their real account it's their burner
it's like no one actually talks [__]
with their face where do you think
social media is going to be like in 10
years do you think that shit's going to
be completely [__] different or you
think it's be I think be worse yeah I
think it's all going to get it might be
like social social credit might actually
you there's going to be a point where we
just say [__] let's scrap all it all
depends on on China's dominance I think
China dominance I was at the airport
yesterday and I I'm looking around like
it's completely packed and every single
motherfucker's on their phone no one's
looking up right no one's looking up and
you know what I say good because before
that you're just sitting in the airport
like this yeah it's better [__] it's
way better way better it's and the
[__] algorithm is so [__] good
dude like there's content for everyone
I'm at J's mom's house and then even J's
mom's on her phone I'm like what's this
[__] old ass lady doing on Tik Tok
and she just follows Bible verses just
[__] people singing hymns [__]
Angels yeah during the day bro and then
she goes to her [__] other account
you know what's funny I read this um one
piece that was written back in the day
when trains were coming out right and
then like they were like oh it's not
what it used to be like you know
etiquette has changed ever since books
like all novels and everything is all
the craze it's like they treated novels
and books the way that we do with phones
they're like no one's interacting
anymore this is the end of society
everyone's just got their face inside of
their novels instead of talking to other
people and I'm like so they've been
thinking that and then they thought that
when the television came out everyone's
at home just like zombies looking at the
TV no one's interacting anymore the
family's not talking it's always [__]
farmer s this [__]
dude cuz there's always going to be
there's always been Farmers there's
always going to be farmers and farmers
are always this [__] way my brother
my brother Kenny is basically a [__]
farmer he talks like that he talks about
all every all the F social Decay but
then that kid's on telegram at every
[__] minute of the day I see his name
on [__] telegram every minute of the
day so I'm like you are you're saying it
but you're not living it bro you know
what would be crazy in 10 years if like
VR becomes is like like a Walkman and
then we're like everyone's at the
airport just [__] VR VR I mean
Apple's got their Pro Vision thing their
Vision Pro dropping this month or some
[__] February but like that's like
that's the best part about it because
right now obviously at 3500 bucks or
whatever [__] nobody's going to get that
[__] right but in 10 years from now cuz
that that's the supposed to be the
fusion between like AR VR so it's like
augmented like where you can see through
it and live your life and like see your
[__] pH [__] you know what I mean
click your and it reads your pupils and
stuff so you can see what you want to
type bus incoming but 10 years from now
it's like that might just be a standard
maybe it's like it's like a circumcision
maybe when your kid's born they just
slip this thing in your [__] eye
already what about this Bart you drive
you drive here from Vegas yep today this
time yep imagine you get in your truck
you lay down you [__] plug into the
system they they drive a spike in the
back of your
head you're [__] F did right and then
you're doing whatever the [__] [__]
around in in in on cyberspace doing
whatever you want to do right playing a
game doing whatever watching probably
bodybuilding videos set to like rock and
roll music or
whatever right and then guess what you
all of a sudden it goes you have arrived
at your destination you unplug the SP
Spike his P out your head you [__] do
that thing from The Matrix where they
like it looks like they're orgasming as
they come out of
the and then you get out and you're here
at JK and then you plug in here at JK so
we can do our
[Laughter]
articles and people have the audacity to
say oh my God look at all these people
their phones can't live with the [__]
moment the moment
sucks I was in the moment yesterday I
got out of LAX I get into a [__] car
and I just sit there you want me to be
in the [__] moment I'm just sitting
there in the back of a car like waiting
45 minutes and stop start traffic like
that's the moment it's not like
Led Zeppelin concerts I'm watching I'm
watching people on New Year's right
people are are doing these [__] posts
like it's like oh I'm in the middle of
I'm in like China or I'm in like like
some of these one of these there's the
tajal look everyone's on their [__]
phone look at everyone's they're not
even enjoying the moment they're taking
a picture of it it's like guess what
dude if phones existed like 200 years
ago that's exactly what the [__]
everyone would be doing too exactly what
everyone we doing too taking a picture
of the stupid Statue of Liberty with a
firework next to it they would be doing
that too so they could [__] be on
their bed and enjoy the moment remember
that time remember that time the moment
just got longer and noticing how much
everyone's not in the moment proves
you're not in the moment either [__]
exactly it's like why are you focusing
on that and plus if you're really
pointing that out you probably weren't
even there no cuz you're mad that
they're not there that's the farmers
dude the farmers are so pissed about it
it's a long shoreman dude
yeah
he